mais alex a une réelle chef du parti
vert au québec
bonjour alex attiré merci d'être avec
nous aujourd'hui sur rt france alors
déjà est ce que cette annonce du premier
ministre québécois est une surprise pour
vous tous plus que le québec fait face à
ce que je sois depuis plusieurs mois on
a un vécu des étapes de confinement qui
se sont rendus un peu plus facile durant
l'été mais da avec le temps froid qui
arrive on voit que le nombre de cas est
en train d'augmenter de façon quand même
assez rapide
on n'est pas du tout dans la même
situation que la france mais je pense
que c'était quand même une bonne
décision et ab dans cette direction de
sperme et avec des restaurants et
beaucoup d'un doigt pour un mois de plus
alors on fonce ni les chefs de partis
sont reçus en ce soir par le premier
ministre pour évoquer l es nouvelles
mesures de restriction est ce que ça a
été le cas aussi pour vous au québec les
autres au québec c'est surtout un
règlement en place qui décide les partis
d'opposition sont consultés de temps en
temps mais il ya beaucoup de gens qui
ont qui justement le gouvernement de
centraliser le beaucoup des pouvoirs de
prédiction au niveau exécutif ressemble
ou de consultation alors les chiffres au
québec
est-ce qu'ils confirment l'efficacité
des mesures prises par le gouvernement
on a réussi à freiner l'augmentation de
code dont le québec se retrouve à peu
près à mi nouveaux cas par jour depuis
maintenant plusieurs semaines
donc ce qui est encourageant c'est qu'on
n'est pas en train de tomber à 12 ou
tourner comme et quand même pour une
population de 8 millions de personnes
milka par jour c'est quand même beaucoup
et on leur travail avec ce qu'on a donc
si malheureuse c'est sûr que les impacts
de ce confinement de sang sont
nombreuses
au plan économique aussi au plan social
parce que quoi que les commerces sont
ouvertes mais les gens sont interdits de
respect de la visite à la maison donc il
ya un prix social qui vient avec son
lieu d un coût en terme de santé mentale
de la population
mais avec un virus aussi dangereux nous
avons très peu d'options vous l'avez dit
un les québécois sont invités à recevoir
à domicile les bars les restaurants des
cinémas ou les musées sont fermés
vous avez dit tout à l'heure que il y
avait certaines réactions l'opposition
politique mais comment réagissent les
québécois c'est assez nouvelle lorsque
les québécois très très grande majorité
la pluie les mesures du gouvernement
ils comprennent très bien la situation
c'est sûr que toujours certains
groupuscules qui manifestent par exemple
quand tu leur donnes ans de porter un
masque dans des espaces publics mais
c'est vraiment un petit mouvement très
marginale puis à la très très grande
majorité des québécois appuient c'est
une mesure de ces ce qui est toujours
d'une discussion sur
à quelles sont nos priorités quels
commerces est ce qu'on veut fermer et et
qui va profiter de tout ça parce qu'il
ya beaucoup de petites entreprises qui
ne seront pas capables de passer à
travers que cette prise de dont une
certaine concentration de du poids
économique dans les mains des plusieurs
entreprises qui ont le cas pour passe à
travers une lectrice quand il livrait
pour protester quand les masses et à
long terme
mais on a un système de santé qui est
pas très très bon état ici des milliers
de sirop gee-gees reporté à cause de
cette crise doit donc chaque fois que
quelqu'un est admis à l'hôpital pour la
covedette de sa garantie tout le
processus de soin le pauvre pour des
gens qui ont des maladies quand même et
porteront pas de suivre le fil de cancer
par exemple qui ont été de pousser donc
on est quand même dans une situation
assez doucement
alors aujourd'hui de le québec est la
province canadienne la plus touchée par
l'épidémie coronavirus qu'au bon on peut
l'expliquer c'est difficilement
explicable et des chefs ici malgré
toutes les mesures du gouvernement a mis
en place
on continue d'augmenter bon on a de la
misère à savons pourquoi que c'est comme
ça ici alors que l'ontario juste à côté
que les deux bouts signale que le québec
quand même un taux d'infection inférieur
à celui du québec
c'est ce cirque
des choses qu'on aurait pu faire mieux
notre niveau des des tests de dépistage
la quantité avec sont disponibles mais
c'est vraiment deux heures pour le
moment pourquoi que le québec se porte
vraiment comme le ppi aux provinces au
canada l'enterrement du taux d'infection
merci beaucoup alex tyrrell d'avoir été
avec nous ce soir sur arte france
je rappelle que vous êtes chef du parti
vert au québec merci beaucoup